en este centro de vacunación de marsella
este la está recibiendo su primera
inyección la vacuna o el despido es el
ultimátum que le dio su empleador no lo
quería de verdad de mis padres también
estaban muy escépticos no querían que le
hiciera pero ya que lo piden en el
trabajo no tengo la posibilidad de
elegir un nivel y hoy estamos obligados
a estar vacunados para todo para moverse
para viajar hoy allí en la región
gonçálves you con la tasa más baja de
vacunación el número de personas que
recibió solo una dosis es también más
alto que en otros lugares desde el
anuncio de la discusión del base de
vacunación en este centro la conclusión
es obvia
ahora tenemos entre 8 y 10 por ciento en
este centro que aplica 2500 vacunaciones
al día superamos las 200 primeras
inyecciones más del doble en comparación
con antes del anuncio del gobierno
al nivel nacional en los últimos siete
días 5% del total de las vacunaciones
eran primeras inyecciones un ligero
repunte en las últimas semanas